- So we're celebrating music's
connection to civil rights.
So, who were your social
musical inspirations?
- Nina Simone and Aretha Franklin.
- [Kelly] Oh yeah, good.
(audience applauding)
- [Kelly] Because they're like,
you know, some of the crème de crème.
- Yeah.
What I found out actually,
whilst I was learning
about both of them,'cause
I sing them a lot,
I sing their music a lot,
is that Aretha was
inspired by Nina Simone,
and she ended up doing
a couple of the songs
that Nina Simone had on her albums.
Young, Gifted and Black.
- Yeah.
- [Cynthia] You know, and obviously
Nina was very much in
the civil rights movement
and her music was about
that at some point.
And they sort of met in the middle,
And both of those women are
huge inspirations for me.
- [Kelly] Yeah,
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] It's interesting
'cause nobody thinks about it,
but one, what was like the first time
you heard Aretha?
- I think I was,
- [Kelly] First question.
- I wanna say I was maybe 10 years old,
in my mother's car on the way to school,
and I think it was Chain of Fools.
- [Kelly] Yeah, I think mine was around 13
and it was Respect or Chain of Fools,
I can't remember which one.
But I just, there was something
different about her voice.
- Isn't it? It just sort of like hits you,
right in the solar plexus.
- Like just breaks you.
- Yeah. And the tone...
But nobody really talks about this,
but she actually did cover
quite a bit of music.
- Yeah she did.
- [Kelly] That was a lot of her career,
which nobody really talked about.
I feel like that's
maybe what influenced me
to do covers all the time,
'cause I love it so much
and I love so many genres.
- She had this wonderful, magical way of
making any song you may have heard,
that belonged to someone else,
sound like it was already written for her
and they were just a
stepping stone to get to her.
- I thought that!
So when I was a kid, I would listen to her
and I was like, oh, I love her song
and they're like, you know that's a cover.
Like, they did that originally.
I was like, wait, what?
- [Cynthia] Respect is a cover!
- That's what I'm saying!
I never knew all those,
I ended up finding that out
and I was like, I didn't...
- Oh, didn't know? Right. Special.
- [Kelly] Nobody wanted
her to cover the song.
(crowd laughing)
- [Cynthia] Oh no.
- Because then it was gone,
it was not yours anymore.